DOWN AND LOCKED AWAY.
A SPECIAL EDITION OF
"SEEN-UNSEEN" WITH RAYMOND
ARROYO.
THAT’S COMING UP, BUT FIRST,
AMERICA IN SHUTDOWN DAY 14.
I WANT TO START WITH THE RAW
NUMBERS.
LET’S KEEP IT UP HERE, GUYS.
MORE THAN 160,000 AMERICANS HAVE
TESTED POSITIVE FOR THE
CORONAVIRUS.
THAT’S OUT OF 944,000 WHO HAVE
BEEN TESTED JUST IN THE LAST
MONTH.
NEARLY 3,000 PEOPLE HAVE DIED.
OF COURSE, NEW YORK IS STILL A
HOT ZONE ALTHOUGH THE STATE’S
RATE OF NEW INFECTIONS
THANKFULLY IS BEGINNING TO LEVEL
OFF.
IT’S A VERY GOOD SIGN, AND WE’RE
GOING TO BRING YOU NEW DETAILS
ON THIS AS THE SHOW CONTINUES.
NOW, LET’S LOOK AT THE NUMBERS.
COULD THE INFECTIONS THERE BE
NEARING A PEAK?
MAYBE.
LET’S KEEP GOING HERE.
COLORADO MAYBE SHOWING A SIMILAR
SENSE OF PROMISE.
WE’LL TALK ABOUT THIS TONIGHT AS
WELL BUT L.A. AND PARTS OF SOUTH
FLORIDA ARE SPIKING AS MORE ARE
TESTED AND MORE ARE
HOSPITALIZED.
THOSE NUMBERS LOOK VERY
DISTURBING.
NOW, THE FDA FAST TRACK, THIS IS
GREAT NEWS, THEY FAST TRACT
APPROVAL FOR THE EMERGENCY USE
OF A DRUG THAT WE JUST MENTIONED
FIRST TWO WEEKS AGO TONIGHT, TO
THE CABLE TV AUDIENCE IN THE
UNITED STATES.
YOU HAD NEVER HEARD OF
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE BEFORE WE
MENTIONED IT.
THIS IS TERRIFIC NEWS.
>> THE PHARMACEUTICAL COMPANY
HAS BEEN WORKING WITH US VERY
CLOSELY, AND AS ALEX MENTIONED A
LITTLE BIT, 30 MILLION DOSES OF
THE HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE TO THE
UNITED STATES GOVERNMENT HAS
BEEN GIVEN, AND BAYERS DOTED A -
DONATED SOME.
ANOTHER DONATED THE DRUG TO U.S.
HOSPITALS.
>> LAURA: WE HAVE PROMISING NEWS
REGARDING IMMUNITY TESTING AS
WELL WHICH WOULD GIVE US
CRITICAL INFORMATION.
MAINLY, WHO AMONG US WON’T GET
COVID-19 BECAUSE OF A NATURAL OR
DEVELOPED IMMUNITY TO IT.
THAT’S INCREDIBLE.
NOW, THOSE FOLKS, PEOPLE WHO
HAVE THAT IMMUNITY COULD
OBVIOUSLY GO BACK TO WORK.
THAT WOULD BE GOOD FOR ALL OF
US.
BUT OF COURSE, MANY OF YOU, AND
I KNOW YOU ARE, BECAUSE I’VE
HEARD FROM YOU, WERE CREST
FALLEN TO HEAR THE PRESIDENT’S
DECISION LAST NIGHT TO EXTEND
THIS NATIONAL SHUTDOWN TO AT
LEAST APRIL 30, AND VIRGINIA
GOVERNOR RALPH NORTHAM ANNOUNCED
HE’S CLOSING DOWN THE STATE
UNTIL JUNE 10, ACKNOWLEDGING
TODAY THAT THIS WOULD HAVE A
DEVASTATING IMPACT ON THE
STATE’S ECONOMY.
HE SAID IT WILL BE REALLY HARD,
YOU THINK?
YES, IT IS.
REALLY HARD.
MARYLAND IS CLOSED INDEFINITELY.
GOVERNOR HOGAN’S STAY AT HOME
ORDER DOESN’T SPECIFY ANY END
DATE THERE SO PEOPLE ARE
WONDERING WHEN WILL LIFE EVER
GET BACK TO NORMAL?
AT THE DAILY BRIEFING TODAY, A
FEW MOMENTS STOOD OUT.
>> SCOTT GOTLEY, YOUR FORMER FDA
COMMISSIONER WROTE A ROAD MAP
AFTER THE RECOVERY VIRUS.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP: I SAW IT.
>> THE ROAD MAP SUGGESTED THAT
EVERYBODY WEAR A MASK IN PUBLIC.
IS THAT SOMETHING THAT THE TASK
FORCE THINKS IS A GOOD IDEA?
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP: WE HAVEN’T
DISCUSSED IT TO THAT EXTENT BUT
IT’S CERTAINLY WE COULD DISCUSS.
WE’RE NOT GOING TO BE WEARING
MASKS FOREVER BUT IT COULD BE
FOR A SHORT PERIOD OF TIME AFTER
WE GET BACK INTO GEAR.
>> LAURA: WAIT A SECOND.
DIDN’T THEY TELL US NOT TO USE
MASKS OR BUY MASKS?
THAT’S COMPLETELY CHANGED.
I GUESS WE’RE LEARNING NEW
THINGS ALL THE TIME.
EVERYONE IS GOING TO HAVE TO
WEAR A MASK FOR THE FORESEEABLE
FUTURE.
WE NEED CLEAR GUIDELINES THERE.
NOW THE FORMER FDA COMMISSIONER
HAS THE PRESIDENT’S EAR.
HE’S HIGHLY RESPECTED BY MANY
INCLUDING DR. ANTHONY FAUCI.
HE SITS ON A NUMBER OF BIG
PHARMA BOARDS, NOTHING WRONG
WITH THAT, AND HE WORKS AT A
VERY PROMISING THINK TANK THE
AMERICAN ENTERPRISE IN
WASHINGTON.
NOW, EVERY AMERICAN ESPECIALLY
THOSE WHO ARE INTERESTED IN
MAKING PLANS FOR THE FUTURE,
SHOULD CAREFULLY READ WHAT SCOTT
GOTTLIEB IS ADVOCATING VIS-A-VIS
THE CORONAVIRUS.
ONE OF THE THINGS HE SAID, HE
BREAKS IT DOWN INTO FOUR PHASES.
IT’S KIND OF INTERESTING BUT ONE
OF THE THINGS HE SAYS, RIGHT NOW
WE’RE IN PHASE ONE AND PHASE ONE
IS ESSENTIALLY TRYING TO CONTAIN
THIS, MITIGATE THIS, DO WHAT
WE’RE DOING NOW.
PHASE TWO WOULD BE MORE STEPPED
UP, YOU KNOW, SOCIAL DISTANCING,
BUT MAYBE WE COULD SLOWLY PULL
BACK IN A FEW STATES.
WE’LL SEE WHERE THAT GOES.
IT ALSO MENTIONS THE TRACKING OF
U.S. CITIZENS.
NOW, THIS WAS ACTUALLY BROUGHT
UP IN THE BRIEFING TODAY.
WHERE THE GOVERNMENT, I GUESS,
WOULD USE GPS TRACKERS.
AGAIN, THIS ISN’T GOTTLIEB’S
LIST OF PROPOSALS TO GET US BACK
TO NORMAL.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THAT?
GPS TRACKING OF U.S. CITIZENS TO
ENFORCE THE STAY AT HOME OR THE
SOCIAL DISTANCING ORDERS.
NOW, WE EXPECTED THAT FROM
RUSSIA AND CHINA.
WOULD THE UNITED STATES USE
THOSE MEASURES?
THE PRESIDENT, WHEN HE RESPONDED
TODAY SAID, WELL, THAT’S PRETTY
SEVERE.
BUT HE ALSO SAID, YOU KNOW, THEY
UNDERSTAND HE’S HEARD ABOUT THIS
REPORT.
MAYBE HE’S READ THE REPORT.
WE ALL UNDERSTAND, AS THIS IS
GOING FORWARD, THAT THE
PRESIDENT HAS A LOT OF
BALANCING.
HE’S GETTING A LOT OF INPUT FROM
A LOT OF PEOPLE, SMART PEOPLE,
AND WE UNDERSTAND HE NEEDS TO
PROTECT THE LIVES OF AMERICANS.
THAT’S CRITICALLY IMPORTANT.
HEALTHCARE WORKERS.
THINK ABOUT THEM.
THEY ARE FEELING THE STRAIN.
WE’VE SEEN THEM ON TELEVISION.
THAT’S REAL.
IN MANY PARTS OF THE COUNTRY,
NOT ALL PARTS BUT MANY PARTS,
STRESS, ANXIETY, THE WORRY, THE
PERSONAL PROTECTIVE GEAR, SOME
OF THEM STILL DON’T HAVE ENOUGH,
AND SOME ARE GETTING SICK
THEMSELVES.
THAT’S REALLY, REALLY
TERRIFYING.
CAN’T BREAK THE SYSTEM.
WE ALL GET THAT.
AND TONIGHT, WE ALSO KNOW THAT
THE ECONOMIC CARNAGE IS PILING
UP AS WELL.
NOW, IT’S ALREADY BEING FELT
COAST-TO-COAST HAVING AN IMPACT
ON WORKING MEN AND WOMEN.
ON THE CHILDREN, THE ELDERLY, ON
THE AT RISK AND LOW-INCOME
FAMILIES, THEY ARE ESPECIALLY,
ESPECIALLY IN HARM’S WAY.
NOW, AGAIN, GOTTLIEB BREAKS DOWN
OUR RECOVERY INTO THOSE THREE
PHASES.
I TALKED ABOUT EARLIER.
RIGHT NOW WE’RE IN PHASE ONE.
IN PHASE TWO WE WOULD BE ABLE TO
GET ON A MODIFIED TRACK.
PHASE TWO HAVE THE OUTBREAK
UNDER CONTROL, COULD SLOWLY
START TO REOPEN SCHOOLS AND
BUSINESSES.
AND PARKS.
BUT WOULD STILL HAVE TO PRACTICE
SOME SOCIAL DISTANCING.
IT WILLING LARGE GATHERINGS,
KEEPING THE ELDERLY AND
VULNERABLE SOMEWHAT ISOLATED.
NOW IN THIS PHASE, TEST WOOING
ALSO NEED TO BE MORE ROUTINE AND
WIDESPREAD THAN IT IS TODAY.
IT SEEMS KIND OF REASONABLE, BUT
WHO KNOWS HOW LONG THAT WOULD
TAKE.
WE’RE TESTING MORE THAN ANY
OTHER COUNTRY IN THE WORLD NOW.
NOT BY PER CAPITAL STANDARDS BUT
WE’VE JUST JACKED THAT UP.
THE WHITE HOUSE HAS STEPPED IN.
BUT IS THIS GOAL TO GET EVEN TO
PHASE TWO?
IS IT ACHIEVABLE BY APRIL 30?
IS IT ACHIEVABLE BY JUNE 30?
THERE ARE A LOT OF THINGS IN
THIS DOCUMENT.
SO WHAT WOULD IT TAKE FOR
AMERICA, YOU MIGHT ASK, IF PHASE
TWO IS NOT EVEN CLEAR TO GET
BACK TO NORMAL LIFE, THE LIFE
YOU HAD BEFORE ALL OF THIS?
THOSE DAYS WHEN KIDS WENT TO
SCHOOL AND PEOPLE WENT TO
SPORTING EVENTS AND WEDDINGS,
RESTAURANT AND CHURCH.
OKAY.
HERE’S DURING PHASE THREE.
THIS IS FROM THE GOTTLIEB
RECOMMENDATIONS.
PHYSICAL DISTANCING RESTRICTIONS
AND OTHER PHASE TWO MEASURES CAN
BE LIFTED WHEN SAFE AND
EFFECTIVE TOOLS FOR MITIGATING
THE RISK OF COVID-19 ARE
AVAILABLE, INCLUDING THEY ARE
BEAUTY PARTICULARS AND A SAFE
AND EFFECTIVE VACCINE.
THAT GOES BACK TO THE GPS
TRACKING.
NOW, WE ALL WANT A VACCINE.
WE’RE PRAYING FOR A VACCINE.
BRILLIANT PEOPLE ARE WORKING ON
THAT RIGHT NOW, BUT ANTHONY
FAUCI TOLD US THAT WOULD BE AT
LEAST 12 MONTHS FROM NOW, IF NOT
18 MONTHS.
THAT’S HOW LONG THE PROCESS
TAKES.
TODAY, JOHNSON&JOHNSON ANNOUNCED
PLANS FOR A CLINICAL TRIAL OF A
COVID-19 VACCINE IN SEPTEMBER.
THAT’S WHEN THE TRIAL WOULD
BEGIN.
BUT LET ME BE CLEAR.
IF GOTTLIEB’S METRICS ARE GOING
TO BE THE ONES THE WHITE HOUSE
USES, IN THINKING ABOUT THIS AND
TALKING TO A LOT OF OTHER REALLY
SMART PEOPLE TODAY CONGRESS
NEEDS TO COME BACK INTO SESSION
LIKE TOMORROW, OKAY?
IF ALL OF OUR SCIENTIFIC
RESOURCES ARE NEEDED TO GET THIS
VACCINE TESTED, DONE, DESIGNED,
AND READY TO GO AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE, SO WE CAN GO BACK TO
BEING A FREE COUNTRY, IF THAT’S
THE METRIC, THEN WE ALL NEED TO
KNOW THAT NOW.
IT’S NOT LIKE AT THE END OF
APRIL, WE’RE TOLD ANOTHER TWO
MONTHS.
NO.
IF WE NEED TO KNOW THE HARD
NEWS, I THINK PEOPLE NEED TO
KNOW THIS NEWS TONIGHT.
AND CONGRESS HAS TO BE HERE TO
HELP FIGURE THIS OUT.
NOW, AMERICANS, I THINK, ARE
EXTREMELY UNDERSTANDING.
THEY WANT TO DO THEIR PART.
WE ALL DO, BUT, IN JUST TALKING
TO A LOT OF FOLKS TODAY FROM ALL
DIFFERENT WALKS OF LIFE,
PEOPLE’S PATIENCE IS NOT GOING
TO LAST FOREVER.
YOU CAN’T BLAME THEM.
THEY ARE UNDER AN ENORMOUS
AMOUNT OF STRESS AND THEY DON’T
HAVE JOBS.
CONGRESS NEEDS TO GET INVOLVED,
GET ACTUAL SPECIFIC METRICS THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION IS USING, TO
DETERMINE WHEN WE CAN HAVE OUR
COUNTRY BACK.
IN EVERY ONE OF THE STATES, ALSO
NOW UNDER A STAY IN PLACE ORDER,
THERE SHOULD BE AN URGENT
MEETING OF THE STATE
LEGISLATURES.
THE GOVERNOR SHOULD BE REQUIRED
TO EXPLAIN, IN EVERY STATE IN
DETAIL, THE FACTUAL AND LEGAL
BASIS FOR HIS OR HER ACTIONS.
THEY MIGHT BE PERFECTLY VALID.
THEY MIGHT BE BASED ON ALL THE
PERFECT PROJECTIONS AND DATA,
AND IF THE PROJECTIONS ARE EVEN
WORSE THAN WE THOUGHT, WE, THE
PEOPLE, HAVE A RIGHT TO KNOW.
IT’S ONLY FAIR.
GIVE US THE FACTS.
GIVE US THE METRICS FOR
RESTARTING THE COUNTRY, THEN WE
CAN DECIDE WHETHER THEY ARE
ACHIEVABLE IN A REASONABLE
AMOUNT OF TIME.
SOME PEOPLE ARE GOING TO LOSE
THEIR HOMES.
MANY ARE GOING TO LOSE THEIR
BUSINESSES, AND OTHERS, THEY ARE
GOING TO LOSE EVERYTHING THEY
WORKED THEIR ENTIRE LIFE FOR.
THEY DESERVE TO HAVE A COMPLETE
UNDERSTANDING OF THE ACTIONS
BEING TAKEN BY THE GOVERNMENT.
ONE OF MY FAVORITE EMAILS OF THE
DAY CAME FROM AN OLD HIGH SCHOOL
FRIEND.
I HAVEN’T HEARD FROM HIM I DON’T
THINK IN MAYBE 17 OR 18 YEARS.
LAURA, JUST AS SCARED AS ANYONE
ABOUT CORONAVIRUS, BUT WE DON’T
HAVE MUCH OF A DEMOCRACY IF
EVERY DIFFICULT DECISION IS MADE
BY TECHCRATS AND THE MEDIA AND
PEOPLE HAVE NO SAY IN THE
MATTER.
I THOUGHT A LOT ABOUT THAT I
GUESS I COULDN’T BLAME THEM.
PROTECT YOUR HEALTH AND THAT OF
OTHERS.
WASH YOUR HANDS A LOT.
USE A GLOVE TO TOUCH OUTSIDE
SURFACES.
SOCIALLY DISTANCE.
IT’S APPROPRIATE, RIGHT THING TO
DO.
HELP THOSE AROUND YOU WHO ARE
HOMEBOUND OR JUST DEPRESSED.
THERE ARE A LOT OF LONELY PEOPLE
THROUGHOUT AS WELL.
LET’S ALSO REMEMBER THAT
CAPITALISM WILL AND IS, FRANKLY,
DELIVERING THE THERAPIES AND WE
HOPE IN THE FUTURE THE CURES FOR
THIS WRETCHED VIRUS.
SO LET’S NOT KILL THE FREE
MARKET IN THE PROCESS OF KILLING
THE VIRUS.
EVERY TIME A COMPANY CLOSES, THE
FLOOD GATE OF ANXIETY AND PAIN
IS OPENED FOR ITS WORKERS.
WE WANT TO STAY SAFE AND FREE.
AND THOSE ARE MY THOUGHTS ON THE